the black death was one of the most
devastating pandemics in human history
between 1347 and 1351 it wiped out 30 to
50 percent of the entire population of
Europe and if there's one animal to
blame it's likely infected fleas making
them one of the deadliest insects in
history
now of course fleas no longer kill
millions of people but as it turns out
they still transmit plague they're still
a nuisance and they're still incredibly
difficult to kill
fleas are one of the oldest pests on the
planet
in fact primitive fleas were dining on
dinosaur blood about 165 million years
ago and they're also one of the most
abundant today there are more than 2,500
species of fleas across the world like
the Kathleen those are the ones you're
most likely to find feasting on your dog
or your cat and then there are species
like the human flea which actually seek
out human hosts specifically and seeking
is a fleas specialty they can sense your
breath your warmth and even the
vibrations of your feet and when they
find you they do what fleas do best
jump according to one study some fleas
can jump nearly a hundred times farther
than the length of their body which
would be like an average man jumping at
nearly a hundred and seventy-five meters
into the air the secret to their spring
is a stretchy protein in their legs
called rezulin and it works like a
rubber band and a slingshot they have
kind of a hook and latch type of system
and when the flea lets go of the latch
they just feel now that makes fleas
difficult to capture and kill but it's
what they do once they land that makes
them a truly terrifying pest first they
use blades in their mouth called
maxillary licinia to tear into your
flesh then they use a straw like
structure called an fo pharynx to slurp
it all up it's not unlike if you spilled
your drink on a table and you took a
straw and you tried to drink it up
yum adding insult to injury fleas have
proteins in their saliva that keep your
blood flowing so they have a constant
supply of food and that's actually why
they itch so much your body or your pets
is reacting to those proteins but
there's one flea that takes feeding to
another more horrifying level and
unfortunately it prefers to prey on
humans Tunga penetrance aka the Chico
flea instead of drinking blood from the
surface of your skin
the females burrow into you and then
they start laying eggs most of her is
buried into the skin but the kind of the
back part where she's releasing eggs is
exposed and fleas lay a lot of eggs up
to 40 each day and as many as 2,000 in
their lifetimes so if your dog brings
back a few fleas from the park you could
soon have thousands and the truth is
they can do a lot worse than make you
itch you see even modern fleas can
transfer diseases like typhus part
analysis and yes plague in fact in the
summer of 2019 the discovery of prairie
dogs infected by plague-ridden fleas
shut down parts of a Denver suburb and
in 2015 a teen reportedly died from
contact with fleas infected with bubonic
plague now fortunately fatal fleas are
pretty rare and most likely it'll be
your pets not you that have to deal with
them but if you do see one or two
jumping around you definitely should try
to get rid of them and here's how first
identify the source and if it's your pet
treat them with an insect growth
regulator like lufenuron next clean your
home though you might want to steer
clear of flea bombs or foggers they're
inconvenient and don't always reach the
nooks and crannies where fleas are
hanging out instead repeatedly vacuum or
mop your floors and toss any bedding
into the washing machine making sure to
dry it at high heat after that all you
can do is sit wait and hope that your
flea free
you
[Music]